what are some of the calculations now
that need to be made and I know that
each state is different as I welcome you
to the program is there an overarching
thing that the president would look at I
think what you just said is the key
thing
states aren't the same some are densely
populated New York New Jersey those
states are maybe needing to be closed
longer but if you're in Wyoming if
you're in Montana if you're in other
parts of rural America
there may not be a reason for you to be
holed up at home like a hermit right now
and that decision is best made closer to
the people who are being affected by it
and that's why I think the president
would be very wise to make this decision
in the hands leave the decision of the
hands of the governors the mayors and
the people who are closest to their
populations some have overreacted Harris
some have been heavy-handed and some of
it is illogical and irrational and I
think they're gonna pay the price for
having usurped people's basic liberties
in it you know we can talk about that
but this is a ramping up of the economy
again it won't happen with the flip of a
switch it will happen with sort of a an
entrance ramp if you will to the freeway
you know I have a follow-up to that
though I'm gonna point out South Dakota
and the governor there and you say some
have been over reacting or heavy-handed
certainly that's the case I mean you see
people protesting now look at Michigan
where they feel like some of those words
are just arbitrary but when you look at
that the popping of the case numbers now
and the problems that they're having
with kovat 19 in a place like South
Dakota that hadn't been a hot spot that
hadn't seen those things and the
governor had taken a different way the
medical professionals though have said
it can happen anyplace and that it
likely will so what do you do with that
it certainly can happen anyplace and I
think this is where the basic protocols
of hand-washing social distancing not
doing you know the traditional handshake
there are some things that still can be
done but we cannot wait until the very
last case of kovat 19 is eradicated but
there is some level of economic activity
in this country there won't be a country
to come back to
that's the calculated risk and it's one
that has to be taken that sounds rather
audacious but Harris I mean we cannot
hold up in our homes for 18 months the
economy won't handle it and I'm not
kidding there will be nothing to come
back to small business owners will not
have a business people who work there
won't have jobs and the good old
government can't just keep shelling out
trillions of dollars indefinitely
there's got to be a point at which we
get back to work we take precautions and
if there does come another hot spot our
let's say a significant outburst then
you deal with it but you deal with it at
that place and at that time you don't
make a blanket one size fits all 50
states shutdown of the entire country